Hazel guys my name is Sharon welcome
back to the series where I grabbed my
first game that I made in Java in C plus
plus
what am I doing why am I doing the intro
like that all right um so welcome back
to this series uh Genesis is the game
where we're creating those of you who
are new here this is what we're making
this is I made this in Java like 11
years ago it's my first game run around
reproducing with women you know
chevron's first game right so what we
did last time episode will be linked up
there is basically my mind that file
um basically we rendered some actual
surprise we read the Sprite sheet that
we had which is this bad boy over here
desperately looking for surprise.png
here it is so we have these Sprites
these are the original Sprites I want to
try not to modify this file at all
because we're trying trying to kind of
Port it in a one-to-one kind of way uh
we have these Sprites and this is little
player character that we decided to test
out and see if we could render and we
can in fact render it here it is we have
some very uh randomly generated pixels
and then right in the middle of the
screen we have this character this
character doesn't have a name
I'm assuming it's implied that it's
a little Channel little channels running
around the island with all the women
that's uh yeah I just don't make games
like I used to anyway so uh we have this
guy we have this character here
um let's continue on with doing whatever
it is that we're doing because and I'm
saying that because I actually don't
know what we're gonna do this episode I
mean it would probably logically make
sense for us to we I guess implementing
that screen class is what I kind of was
was meaning to do so that's what we
actually set out to do I think in the uh
in the last episode but then we realized
that instead of implementing the screen
class which is basically like the
renderer right it's what takes all the
pixels and actually writes them into
like the the screen buffer
um we couldn't really do that until we
read in some pixels to render meaning
like some Sprites to render which is why
we spent the last episode creating the
Sprite sheet class and I haven't
actually pushed this ticket yet I know I
said I would but I never got around to
it so I'm sorry but um I will probably
do that today
uh or at least before this episode goes
out so yeah let's continue and probably
implement or start implementing this
screen class and let's kind of go
through it very Loosely because I think
I did go through it like one or two
episodes ago maybe even in the first
episode
um okay so the screen class is pretty
simple it's a class that we actually
pass into every other class for some
reason so instead of just making the
class kind of static and Global because
obviously we only have one screen that
we render
um and uh we use this literally for like
this contains the pixels buffer well
this actually contains its own pixels
buffer which is basically just like this
kind of um array that we have it's a
one-dimensional array obviously but it's
kind of interpreted as a two-dimensional
array uh where we have obviously width
and kind of height we have all of the
pixels that we have in our screen and
they're integers right so they're 32-bit
integers which contain a color and it
looks like they basically contain a
32-bit color so even though
we might not really have our the concept
of alpha we still need to kind of render
Alpha so usually we just set that
channel to FF just because the image
happens to be in a 32-bit format that's
all
um or in an rgba format I should say and
then we have obviously um I think our
blue Channel and then our green Channel
and I'm writing two characters here each
character is referring to one byte but
in hexadecimal two digits represent one
byte that's why I'm writing it out like
this and then obviously we have the red
Channel as well so this kind of is
obviously our one byte for red one byte
for green one byte for blue and one byte
in the most significant bits for our
Alpha channel that is the image format
uh and so we just have to kind of write
that class around that so what it's
supposed to do is just copy pixels into
this pixels buffer so if I had to
summarize this class in like one
sentence it would be all of these
functions all of basically all of them
apart from set offset maybe but all of
these functions effectively write in
integers into this pixels array that's
all they do and then the game class will
eventually copy them again for some
reason but it will you can see it copies
from screen.pixels into its own pixels
buffer which is taken from this image
which is eventually drawn using Java's
Graphics so that is the kind of
explanation okay I don't know if anyone
cares because this is Java but
you know that's my video I'm just going
to make it the way I want to make it
feeling unnecessarily feisty today all
right anyway so
um yeah and then we have this clear
function which also writes pixel zero so
let's start kind of implementing that
now of course we don't have to we don't
have to pull this game one one to one
and I'm not going to do that that's a
bit silly for a number of reasons first
of all because I've learned a lot
hopefully since
all the way back then but also because
there's just like some of the things
that I've done
there's just no point in doing it that
way so let's make namespace Genesis
class uh screen so I I think what I'm
going to do for one is I'm actually
probably not going to call it screen I'm
just going to call it renderer
the reason being I just don't see the
need to call it screen
um again I'm pretty sure I called it
screen because Notch called his class
screen uh and at that point I had no
idea what I was doing so I was like I
guess that's what people do uh you know
just typical typical child things
because I believe I was 17 when I made
this so technically a child
um so we have to think about how we want
this renderer to work because
what actually happened in the Java
version funnily enough so remember
screen is basically renderer and there
is no class called renderer like that
does not exist
um so what does what the way the screen
class worked as you can see is
level.render was used inside this render
function that basically went through and
Drew every tile and every like other
Sprite so trees were like drawn on top
or parts of them were anyway
um and also like torches were drawn on
top and obviously the characters like
the the male and the female Sprites they
were drawn on top of those tiles but
basically level.render was responsible
for all of that and you can see it
actually takes in screen the renderer as
a parameter and if we look at that
when it when it wants to draw a tile it
again takes screen in as a parameter now
we can think about like whether or not
this is required because at the end of
the day if we actually look at game
it's funny back then like I made a lot
of stuff static as you can see like a
lot of stuff static and public because I
was I did not really know anything about
and remember I had not I had taught
myself programming like my the first
time in my entire life where someone
actually taught me like programming was
in university when I was like 18. so
like the year after this basically
um in in high school like I didn't learn
any programming at all so this was all
kind of self-taught stuff so of course
like to me I was just like I need access
to this data and this other thing I had
no idea about design principles or
anything like that so for me it was just
like make this stuff static but funnily
enough screen would have actually been
something that I think realistically
should have probably been static and not
just the instance of it I mean you could
make the instance of it static but like
the the way the class was structured in
itself probably should be static because
as you can see the instance of screen
really just gets created in this file
this horrific find and replace feature
like why are you like this
um and then in the Constructor of game
you can see that it calls like screen
equals new screen it calls a Constructor
it instantiates that object and that's
it so it is kind of you know when you
make the instance of the game which is
this class and you only do that once in
the main function you also make an
instance of screen and you never like
recreate you never do anything with it
so the whole class really is just
completely static right and then you can
see Sprite sheet is another good example
of that right it doesn't even get
assigned to an object it's just like a
new Sprite sheet the reason being is
brighter class itself has public static
stuff so that's how we access it so this
didn't even really need a Constructor
you could have just made like you know
these uh you know could have made a
static function called load sheet and
you don't need this Constructor in the
first place you can just you know call
Sprite sheet Dot load sheet or whatever
and then pass in that thing and you'd be
done so there are some interesting kind
of
design I guess decisions here but anyway
my point here is just that when we think
about this screen class and we think
about whether or not we actually need to
make an instance of it and then we pass
it into literally everywhere that begs
the question of can we just make it like
a global kind of object or a static
object now
in general
I like to avoid doing that I'll explain
why it's because they're
there can be like realistically in lots
of projects that end up being bigger so
if you're working on something like a
game engine
there will always be
uh well not all I can't guarantee this
obviously but in my experience it's very
very likely that you will then realize
actually there is a pretty good use case
for having two of these so like a really
good example is like in Hazel we have we
basically have two kind of renderer
classes well we have more than that but
we have something called a renderer 2d
and we have something called uh a scene
renderer and we also have like a
renderer which is mostly just API
commands but anyway scene renderer is
responsible for basically taking in a
scene and producing an image out of it
so it's kind of the high level thing
that actually organizes all the render
passes and does all the rendering now
you would think that maybe having one of
them would be enough and certainly for a
game it might be
but then what you can do is you can
think of different scenarios in which
maybe you want more than one and so a
really good use case that we have is
what if you have multiple viewports
so you need to render the scene from
different perspectives
now traditionally the scene renderer is
supposed to only create one image right
so it takes in a Scene It produces an
image one image
you could extend it to support multiple
images but then you need to think about
multiple camera perspectives but it's a
viewport in an editor so maybe it also
has different graphic settings like
maybe you want this to be wireframe
maybe you want that to not be wireframe
what about if you're playing like a
multiplayer game and you have split
screen so you also need to render the
scene again usually it's the same scene
but it's in different perspectives what
if you're if your level editor supports
opening multiple scenes at once and then
docking them to different tabs so that
you can kind of see two scenes side by
side we need more than one scene
renderer clearly so if we make that
whole thing static that sucks
additionally because of the way that
Vulcan works we can also take advantage
of of running those scene renderers in
completely different CPU threads because
we can build up those Vulcan command
buffers on separate threads and then
eventually kind of come together to
submit them to the GPU so we kind of
wind up with these scenarios where if we
design everything in kind of a static
way like in a global way
and and we only enforce the kind of
you're only allowed one instance of this
then that can be really limiting in the
future now
does that apply to us here and that's
probably the biggest question we can
answer
to static or not to static is really the
the question possibly the title of this
video if we had like this is a very
simple game and perhaps if we maybe
decided along the way that we want to
add Co-op multiplayer to this then
perhaps in that scenario you would
probably want more than one instance but
I think that for the most part
we probably only want one and in fact
the difference here is that even if we
did only have one instance of this
renderer like because the renderer is
just copying pixels onto the screen like
we could easily just kind of write that
kind of you know make that split screen
make that division like if we had like a
you know one of these divisions or one
of these divisions or whatever we could
easily divide this crane into two and
kind of do that at a higher level than
the renderer so the renderer just knows
about the one image right so we have one
image and because we're rendering all
the pixels we could just kind of render
to half the viewport basically so we can
divide the viewport in half and just be
like okay we'll actually render to half
of this the only possible thing that we
might need to do and which would
actually be difficult to do without
modifying the render class would be like
what happens if a Sprite is you know
half off the viewport right so if the
viewport divider is this green line and
we have a Sprite that really would look
you know like that
but it's kind of this part obviously
needs to get basically get clipped off
you know can we set like a scissor
region or something to do that and that
would probably involve the renderer
anyway we're getting way deep into this
that's just what I have a habit of doing
sometimes so I'm sorry if you don't
enjoy that but um let's just start
implementing it and
again to be completely honest I think I
am going to make it static in this case
just because like at the end of the day
we are going to have a global image and
if we make it static it's just going to
be way easier to access now you can like
you can also go halfway between static
and not static right so for example
um what I mean by that is if we go back
to what's this Genesis app
um we have one image here and we have
what we could do is we could basically
create you know one renderer as well and
that renderer could be like our you know
primary image renderer because it
targets that specific image
um
uh renderer
do I rename it to renderer I did so this
kind of renderer right might Target that
primary image but then if we have
another image you know we could make
another kind of secondary image renderer
that targeted that image now you also
really have to think about
[Music]
um
I guess the object-oriented nature of
this like why are we fundamentally
creating two different instances of the
renderer class what does that even mean
we're getting kind of almost existential
crisis kind of
uh here basically what I'm saying is
that the reason why these are instances
in general and we're going to provide
obviously a bunch of functions here such
as you know draw Sprite and perhaps
that's going to take in you know some
parameters obviously and it's going to
draw the Sprite now if we provide a
function like this and then we end up
being able to call stuff like primary
image renderer draw Sprite versus
secondary image renderer draw Sprite why
are these part of a class right like
what why not just make these Global
functions that don't belong to a class
well the reason why we add this kind of
class uh not overhead but like
abstraction I guess on top of the raw
functions is to provide context
so we're not doing anything fancy here
like and there's no like polymorphic
types here it has nothing to do with
like you know different implementations
of certain classes which might differ in
Behavior it's more so just you're
providing context and the context itself
is basically the image you're rendering
to so your draw Target your render
Target that becomes the contacts that we
provide with this actual class so it's
almost like if you think about it this
way it's almost like we're providing a
function to the image class and then
we're able to be like hey image draws
Sprite versus like my second image which
doesn't exist but my second image draw
Sprite on that image but we're doing
that without really modifying this image
class because that's very like that has
nothing to do with our rendering we
don't want to couple that together
because it's just an image right it
shouldn't have a function like draws
Prime that's very specific but in a way
where kind of creating a class which
then contains the image and that way
it's almost like we're creating an
attraction that lets us draw Sprite on a
specific image because a renderer is
going to kind of hold and own a specific
image that is its render Target if that
makes sense now
of course I can earn much more context
than that as well so you might have
certain render settings you might have
screen regions as I mentioned if you
have viewports so for example we could
make this primary image renderer only
take up kind of this space and be like
that's your allowable render space which
means stuff outside that would get
clipped versus you know this second
secondary image renderer which would
only be allowed to render here so there
can be much more kind of uh I guess
context that can go on top of that
although I guess in this case your
images would be half size anyway but
still like you could create like certain
clipping regions do whatever you want
render settings maybe you want certain
Graphics turned on here certain effects
turned off there I don't know they might
have you might even kind of build in
like a camera into this actual renderer
so that you can Define like where the
camera kind of is so where is this
renderer rendering from where's the
primary kind of viewport or Viewpoint I
guess like the camera where is it
because that's obviously where you're
rendering from that could be part of
that context as well so that you can
just call draw Sprite and you don't have
to be like yeah but where's the camera
like is this Sprite even on the screen
or should it be like offset off
somewhere so there's a lot of like
there's really a lot of discussion we
can employ here
um and then you know what you can do
though in this case if we wanted to
avoid kind of uh sending this uh image
renderer into every single like class
that needed to use it so if we had a
level class eventually yeah and then we
wanted to do like render and then we had
to obviously pass in then the primary
image renderer to that like if we wanted
to avoid doing what we did in Java which
is again passing the screen everywhere
you know into level render then later
into tile render we could still make it
kind of static at this application Level
so that's something that sometimes
people don't realize I guess they think
that the class itself has to fully be
static but then what you're doing here
is you're saying by by writing code like
this you're saying that there's only
going to be one instance of basically
this like entire class and that's it and
that's obviously very limiting because
you might want to create multiple
instances with different render targets
as I mentioned and so what you can do
instead is you can leave this not static
but then you can make this static right
and so now it's like you like these
things are kind of like it's almost like
you're making an instance of renderer
that is going to be shared across every
instance of Genesis app of sorry of game
layer Genesis app is the CPP file we're
in but of game layer right and then so
in a way also what we're doing is it's
like we're making game layer static
we're saying that there's only going to
be one instance of game layer
um because even though gameplay is
allowed to have separate instances of
these guys because they're not static
Within game layer we're saying that
we're not really going to have more than
one game layer therefore you can make
this static because it's okay to kind of
have uh these be shared across instances
um and then a diff another solution
would be
to make game layer static now game layer
again is created normally here and it's
used here but what we can what we can
really easily do is we could kind of
make it into a Singleton so what I can
do is uh and again we still kind of want
the instance to be created because you
can see that what happens is the layer
gets pushed here and then the owner of
the layer is going to be application we
push it into game layer and then what
that does you can see is it makes shared
and it puts into the layer stack so the
layer stack is the data structure that
actually owns like the shared pointer to
this actual layer but still what you
could do if you wanted to is you could
absolutely make
um
well first of all we could we could use
it as a shared pointer you could use it
as a raw pointer you could make it as a
weak pointer if you wanted to the
possibilities are endless shared points
is just going to keep the object alive
which again is probably not what you
want but what we could do is we could
get the game layer
um or actually let's do it maybe let's
do it this way we could make it and I
think this is probably the solution I'll
go with but you can see there's so many
moving Parts here so many possibilities
and I'm trying to I'm being extremely
verbose here but I'm trying to actually
that reminds me of a comment
that I read on the last episode let me
just see if I can find that aha Nick
said honestly it's a bit too verbose for
me I would prefer to see more coding and
less explanations at this point that's
the whole point of Cherno well thank you
awesome turtle
um but like in all seriousness like
again this series is made for kind of
beginners so I'm trying to communicate
what's going on in my brain because
that's kind of the point of this series
and then the fact that we're doing these
two Genesis and we're porting Genesis
into C plus plus that's just like the
the the medium the medium of the
education and the knowledge transfer
hopefully because of course it could be
anything but I've just chosen this
because why not anyway so what we're
doing here is we're actually making a
static weak pointer uh two game layer
which we'll call you know game layer
instance and you can see I've kind of
made it Global uh in a way it's static
and it's outside of the class so it's
not static as in you know static Insider
class which means that it's kind of
shared across all instances of that
class what it means is that it's kind of
internal to this file so you can't
access gameplay instance outside of this
file directly now here's what we're
going to do inside game layer somewhere
as a function we're just going to write
a function that's going to return a game
layer pointer called get instance uh or
you could call it just get as well
um and then what that's going to do is
that's going to be static
that's going to basically return
gameplay instance but the reason why I
didn't make this a raw pointer which I
could have and to be completely honest
like you can do that um in fact in this
case it probably work but I've I'm
trying to demonstrate something so I've
made it a weak pointer which again isn't
bad but what we have to do is we
basically have to check the validity of
that first so there's two functions here
expired or lock now expired will just
return a Boolean really easy for you to
check to see if it's still alive lock
however the cool thing about lock is
that it will actually return a shared
pointer of what you want so we could
have a shared pointer of game layer
called like our instance or whatever and
then we can just return like if we
wanted a either a raw pointer we could
do instance dot get and then we'd get a
raw pointer which could be null or what
we could do is also change the return
type to specifically be a shared pointer
and then we will return this now why on
Earth would you do it this way
instead of just having a raw pointer the
only real benefit here is that if the
object gets destroyed we specifically
get
null here so the whole idea of this is
that basically it allows us to check
whether or not game layer instance has
actually been destroyed so it has the
app been destroyed and has it destroyed
kind of the game layer instance along
with it because basically what this lock
function does in a way is I guess it
just checks to see if the object has
expired or not and if it's expired it
gives us back null otherwise it gives us
back a shared pointer of the object now
why a shared pointer of the object
because now it will be kept Alive by
whoever uses it so the kind of scenario
here is very simple in a way it just
means that if we call get if the
sequence is and remember this can be
multi-threaded if the sequence is we
call get that calls this lock function
which creates a shared pointer and
returns it to us and now we might be
using it somewhere an application might
decide you know what it's time to delete
it so when it does that when this
application goes out of scope and our
game layer goes out of scope since we've
obtained a new shared pointer to that
object we actually still keep this
object alive and only when we're done
and we release it will the reference
count go back to zero and it will be
completely destroyed so that's just like
an extra safety layer
um and obviously if you return this and
it's null because this is just a like a
blank shared pointer is what you'll get
back here and we could obviously
simplify this to that then that's
totally fine uh we can just kind of like
the core e can just make sure that the
app that you've gotten actually contains
like a valid pointer if it needs to and
so this is just a way to kind of not
prevent it from dying as you can see
because if we made this a shared pointer
right if I just make this a shared
pointer and then we just return this
what does that mean that means I have a
global shared pointer instance here so
game layer instance will never die
unless I explicitly uh reset it
and then if no one else has the instance
it will die
right so that's bad because I don't want
to keep it alive because that's app
that's the application class as a
responsibility right so instead what I
do is I make it a weak pointer so that
it's like it it just has a reference to
it but it's a non-owning reference it
won't stop it from dying and then I can
just see if it's still alive because
again if it's not it will just return
null so I think one last thing I'll do
to just give some extra Clarity to those
who need it is I'll basically write it
out this way if expired then basically
this will just return null
otherwise it will return lock which
again I think that's all we can really
call isn't it we can't get the raw
pointer out of this
no so lock is kind of that's effectively
what's going on here we're returning
null if that has in fact died otherwise
we're returning
um
like a shared pointer instance of that
and then what can you do with this well
if you're in another class such as again
a bad example because we don't really
have many classes but let's just say
it's Sprite sheet then what we can do is
we can just be like hey game layer I
want to get your instance and then we
can do a couple things uh let me just
include this again I'm going to this
very temporary I'll get rid of this and
it's actually called
genesisapp.h oh we don't even have a
header for this I just realized oh
wonderful so we're gonna have to move
that out into a into a header file
that's funny but let's just say we were
trying to render something and we're in
here and this isn't in the game layer
then we can basically just be like hey
game layer get and there's two ways we
could go around this we could basically
either then check to see if that
instance is alive by using that shared
pointer and then we can you know do
anything we want with game such as
access like the primary image render or
the second uh secondary image renderer
right we'd need functions for that or we
need to make it public of course but
then we can kind of you know we're
actually in the game class here so we
can just kind of access that and that's
all good or we can even do a little
shortcut if we know that it's going to
be alive or we're fine with crashing if
it's not
um we can just kind of do that and get
access to that and so you can see that
in a way and then called Ross Pride so
you can see in a way it's like we've
made it Global we have because we can
just go through game layer get and then
that and then which specific render do
we want to access so that gives us the
kind of necessary tools I guess to
perform that task however you can see we
can still have two image renderers so
that's still Superior to just making
this static now are you ever going to
have two game layers see this is where
again it's going to get complicated
because you could go infinitely deep
here maybe you have two running
instances of your application that you
kind of want to obviously be in the one
instance so therefore you do want to be
able to create multiple instances of
game layer this conversation could go on
forever but hopefully the kind of
insight I've given you here today can
help you if you were like me and you
were just constantly making everything
static because you had no idea how to
make two different classes or two
different files communicate between them
what I've done here is I've shown you
like a robust way to kind of make game
layer a Singleton to make it globally
accessible but that is probably a
reasonable assumption to make because
that's like your primary application
layer you're really only going to have
one instance of that and I've shown you
how to do that in kind of a Safeway
where it's not going to possibly like
either keep the object alive literally
forever or potentially result in a crash
because you can always check the
validity of that object and also when
you do start using the object it won't
die since you're kind of returning a
shared pointer now obviously this won't
work at the moment because we're not
actually setting as gamma instance to
anything at all so what we need to do is
when game layer gets created over here
we call void push layout now at the
moment we're using this function which
will internally make that shared pointer
and then it will actually return nothing
to us what we want to do is we want to
make it ourselves and then use this push
layer function to emplace it back here
at which point it will do the same thing
and call untouch and that's fine so the
only difference here is that if we come
down here we'll have to basically write
shared pointer game layer
and we'll call this
game layer or in fact what we could do
really uh we don't even need that we
could just do I don't know that's a weak
pointer never mind so we'll make the
shared pointer down here game layout
we'll say
um
equals STD makes shared
game layer
so we make it like that and then we just
do push layer without the template
arguments game layer and what that lets
us do is obviously retain this shared
pointer so that we can then make a weak
pointer out of it by just kind of
assigning it to game layer instance like
so now the reason that's not working is
because we actually made this game layer
instance above this game layer class so
it actually doesn't know what type that
is because we haven't declared the type
until down here now there's a few
different ways you can fix that
basically we kind of need to make sure
that this is I guess declared a bit
lower perhaps like over here however
what that means is that we can't really
call this get function so what we can do
eventually we'll move game layer to be
in its own file I just don't want to do
that today so I'll show another another
way of doing this we could just
basically take the definition of this
function which is the thing that uses
game layer instance and actually push it
to be below that so the Declaration
still stays up here but you can see it's
just we haven't defined the function and
then down here we'll take this
uh we'll add the game layer
uh kind of class scope to that so that
that's uh obviously referring to that
because you can see that's outside of
the class the class ends here right this
is the whole game layer class if I
Collapse it you can see it's contained
here this is outside of it but it
implements a function it provides a
function definition for that specific
function in that class and then that's
obviously used down here and we can
still do that so if we do Ctrl F7 that
should build successfully and then if we
wanted to of course we could now kind of
just call get like I am over here and
that should in fact work now whilst
editing one thing that I noticed that I
completely forgot to point out is why
would we not just make primary image
renderer and secondary image render a
static like we could do this and I did
briefly show that but I didn't really
explain why I chose not to do that and
why I've kind of essentially made game
layer static or made it a Singleton by
keeping this kind of game layer instance
as like a global weak pointer because if
we do make this static like this what
that means is that we technically don't
need game I get at all we can just
immediately address these image
renderers through game layer like that
now this is of course like a completely
viable option you could do it this way
as well but really the only
consideration here is the lifetime of
these renderers and that's really why I
chose not to do that because what
happens is if you declare a static
variable in a class when does that die
certainly not with the class because
it's not part of the class it's static
so what happens is that unless you
explicitly say in the destructor which
we don't even have at this point but if
we had a Destructor for game layer and
we reset that specific weak pointer or
sorry shared pointer right because these
are shared pointers so if we
specifically reset them and nothing else
is holding that reference then sure like
it will delete it and basically what
that means is that the destructure of
renderer will get called and that object
will kind of be freed from memory if you
do not do that though explicitly because
this is static
it just kind of exists it exists forever
just like this but the difference is
that this is a weak pointer so it's not
actually keeping it alive if something
else deletes it if all the references
are released from that shared pointer
it's dead so hopefully that kind of
shows you why I would prefer not to make
them static like this but just make game
layer static because that kind of gives
us access to all of these variables
globally as long as we of course provide
public ways of accessing them however it
does not like screw with the lifetime of
them at all because they're still kind
of member variables and they're still
tied to the existence of game layer
which again we're not taking over
because we're making it Global because
it's a weak pointer alright bit of an
episode today where we basically wrote
no code but hopefully this was some good
uh discussion regarding like two static
or not to static didn't expect it to
turn into this but that's the beauty of
this series it's just like whatever
happens happens and that's just the way
it's going to be thank you guys for
watching my hair just went up thank you
guys for watching hope you enjoyed the
video don't forget to hit the like
button if if you did and I will see you
next time goodbye